[Music]
so I'm Gilbert Strang and this is about
my new course 1806 5 and the new
textbook linear algebra and learning
from data and what's in those subjects
so they're really two essential topics
and two supplementary but all of them
very important subjects so if I tell you
about those four parts of mathematics
that are in the course that'll give you
an idea if you're interested to follow
through so the first big subject is
linear algebra that subject has just
surged exploded in importance in
practice what I want to focus on is some
of the best matrices say symmetric
matrices orthogonal matrices and their
relation those are those are the stars
of linear algebra and the key step is to
factor a matrix into may be symmetric
times orthogonal matrix may be
orthogonal times diagonal times
orthogonal matrix that's a very
important factorization called the
singular value decomposition that
doesn't get into a lot of linear algebra
courses but it's so critical so can I
speak now about the second important
topic which is deep learning so what is
deep learning it's the job is to create
a create a function you have your inputs
are like for driverless cars the input
would be an image that's a telephone
pole or a pedestrian and the system
to learn to recognize which it is or the
inputs from handwriting on on addresses
would be a zip code so the system has to
learn how to recognize 0 1 2 3 up to 9
from handwriting of all kinds or another
one is speech like what Siri has to do
so my speech has to get input and
interpreted and output by the process of
deep learning so it involves creating a
learning function the function takes the
input the data and produces the output
the meaning of that data and so how
what's the function like that's what
mathematics is about functions so it
involves mate it involves matrix
multiplications part of the function is
multiplying vectors by matrices so
that's a bunch of steps but if there was
only that if it was all linear algebra
the thing would fail and has failed what
makes it work now so much that companies
are investing enormous Lea in the
technology is that there's now a
nonlinear function a very simple one in
the middle between every pair of
matrices and that not only function I
can even tell you what it is it's the
function f let's call it f f of X is
equal to X if X is positive and f of X
is 0 if X is negative so you can imagine
its graph it's a flat line where it's
negative and then it's a 45-degree slope
where it's positive so putting that
nonlinear function in between the matrix
multiplications is the way to construct
learn successful learning function but
you have to find those matrices so I
mentioned to supporting subjects
the first is optimization would be the
we have to find the entries in those
matrices that go into the learning
function that's a crucial step so this
is a problem of minimizing the error
with all those matrix entries as
variables so this is multivariable
calculus like a hundred thousand five
hundred thousand variables is just
unthinkable in basic calculus course but
it's happening in in a company that's
working with deep learning and so that's
it that's the giant calculation of deep
learning that's what keeps GPUs going
for a week but it gives amazing results
that could never have been achieved in
the past so then the other key subject
is statistics and the basic ideas of
Statistics play a role here because when
you're multiplying a whole sequence of
matrices in deep learning it's very
possible for the numbers to grow out of
sight exponentially or to drop to zero
and both of those are bad news for the
learning function so you need to keep
the mean and variance at the right spot
to keep those numbers in the learning
function those matrices in in a good
range so it's you this course won't be a
statistics course but it will use
statistics as deep learning does so
those are the four subjects linear
algebra and deep learning two big ones
optimization and statistics essential
also so I hope you'll enjoy the videos
and
that takes both and go to the
OpenCourseWare site ocw.mit.edu
for the full picture beyond the videos
there are exercises problems discussion
lots more toward making it a complete
presentation which I hope you like
you